- Chaque année, des centaines
de milliers de vieux frigos et
de climatiseurs bourrés de gaz
toxiques pour l'environnement
se retrouvent à la rue puis à
la ferraille, sans passer par
le recyclage. "C'est une grave
erreur", dit le directeur
général de GoRecycle.
JULES FOISY LAPOINTE,
directeur général, GoRecycle
- En 2021, GoRecycle a ramassé
83 309 appareils et a évité
ainsi le rejet de 87 000 tonnes
de GES.
- L'organisme, qui regroupe des
recycleurs et des détaillants
d'électroménagers, a mis sur
pied un réseau de 260 points
de dépots d'appareils en fin
de vie utile.
- Tout le monde connait
un voisin qui met un frigo,
un climatiseur en bord de rue,
malheureusement souvent
ces appareils-là vont être
dégazés en bord de rue,
essentiellement les gaz vont
être rejetés dans l'atmosphère
ou sinon rendu chez
le ferrailleur.
- Ces gaz, qu'on appelle
des halocarbures, sont
particulièrement toxiques
pour l'atmosphère.
Au Québec, plus de 300 000
appareils réfrigérants sont mal
recyclés chaque année, causant
le rejet de 300 000 tonnes
de GES; soit l'équivalent
de 100 000 voitures
routes.
- La meilleure chose à faire,
c'est de le rapporter ou
sinon d'utiliser un détaillant
qui offre un service de collecte
à domicile.
- GoRecycle souhaier
70 % des vieux appareils
réfrigérants d'ici 2024,
et 90 % d'ici 2028.
Pour y arriver, i
convaincre les indécis,
nquants, et améliorer
la chaine de transport entre
le consommateur et l'entreprise
de recyclage.
MATHIEU FILION
directeur général, PureSphera
- C'est toute une question auss,
de volume, plus ces volumes-là
sont importants, donc plus
les gains environnementaux sont
important aussi et tout le monde
en bénéficie.
- Le gouvernement versera
jusqu'à 90 millions de dollars
dans les dix prochaines années
pour souefforts
de GoRep<</OÑ
BENOIT CHARETTE, ministre
de l'Environnement, Québec
- L'engagement financier est
sur quelques années, mais c'est
certain que lorsque le réseau
ération sera mature,
cette impulsion budgétaire
de la part du gouvernement
n'aura plus sa place.
- Les entreprises spécialisées
peuvent récupérer et recycler
jusqu'à 95 % des pièces et
des gaz d'un réfrigérateur
hors d'usage.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon